私娘社長チャンネルチャンネル登録じゃろ
100万人とこそさーん
半年前でまぁ u 2は10万人を超えると金の再生ボタン100万件を超えると金の
再生ボタンが奢られるというシステムになっておりましてようやく服
のところにも金の再生ボタンが届いたわけなんですよ
ここばこの子の大きさですからねこの中にマーキンの3食パンが入っているんですよ
今後の一因かどうかって物とは寛大な本当に憂鬱4さんありがとうございますでですね
ましてっ
まだ開けないしたよまだいけないんですけども設計チェッキンの先生ボタンきたという
ことでです今日
この後僕ちょっととげきさんの家ピックんですけどもうちょっと3脚エネルギーの再生
ボタンとこの金な先生もとすり替えてあの日から気づくかどうかを実験的に確かめて
みようと思いますがも4
たびたびよってますよねー
んじゃあ
パーッ
何っラブライブ
アルカナカード
ん
8時だヨあんまり時間がないので頑張っていきましょう
いますお風呂に入ってます開きましょう
9番人
いつも見てくださってチャンネル登録してくださって皆さんありがとうございます
皆さんがいてくれるからこそ始めたそうだと思っているのでこれではもう言う
しくお願いします本当に一ありがとうねこれからもですよみんなが面白いと言って
くれるとかもあるし
ながつまらないってくれる所もあるかもしれない
北
をもそろいで終わらせるつもりはないんです僕自身から他のすべての動画を出している
ときなのですー
これから金ユルってねって言っていこうと思っていますこれからも皆さんの応援で僕は
ん
楽しく youtube に動画を出していこうと思っていくのでまたよろしくお願い
しますということで改造
でかいぞ
いうお写真が入ってるはこちらです
にゃんステーションはんです
乳がんビデオさん使えます
持っん
殉教者と思って
ブーバーにある日案を小さくたにチェンジしたブーバーだから夏気付かないと思うよ
これはもう一基妻やっ前違いがにょます
した
ススメはん
スターそ
ん
th
これダンボールさ
ユーザーというふうに反してください俺らちゃんだ